the jurogan experience well obviously i
was doing those shows with dave
until he got there and what was that it
was it was just here
theater okay stubbs has a 400 seat
amphitheater
and uh so we tested the entire crowd and
then um
someone in dave's circle not related to
the show
got coveted and was hanging around with
dave got dave sick
got three or four other people sick
radio raheem got sick
um uh the photographer's son got sick i
don't know if the photographer got sick
a lot of guys got sick
and get it no no elon already had it
okay
elon had it in the past and a lot of
people were saying that his
girlfriend grimes gave it to dave that's
not true no it was another guy that gave
it to dave
his girlfriend grimes had gotten over it
already long before
like several days before she got to the
show you yeah you
i don't know maybe you have the blood
type or you just built different way
you're just
you're not the guy who's gonna get
coveted i don't know man but
i always got a show we'll see i was at a
show
um with uh several people
that wound up getting coveted because i
went to the show
and uh i didn't expect that it was gonna
be like so covety
everybody was just gonna feel it out
here bro
people don't give a [ __ ] they just go
out but the thing you should see florida
yeah oh i know dude i did a show for new
year's eve i walked out and there's
it was just everyone's together and i
come i'm like
do you guys not get the news like listen
i'm pretty loosey-goosey but it's
ridiculous
and i see a guy making up with two
chicks in the front i go hey hold on
stop
do you know each other like no i'm like
what the [ __ ] you doing man
they're not worried about it no they
don't care man do you know about
uh quercetin and zinc yeah all those
different medic or different nutrients
yeah for people that didn't listen to
the mark gordon podcast i'd recommend
you listen to it because it's actual
peer-reviewed studies on quercetin which
is something called an ionophore
which gets ions into the cells and then
you take that with zinc
has a much higher absorption rate of
zinc and according to dr gordon it
essentially like
stops viruses dead in its tracks when
you when you take this on a regular
basis even covered
yeah and i'm i'm just on i have not
wavered even a little on my vitamins me
neither i stay unless i got covered
right i was like the
canary in the coal mine for comics you
were there earl was the first one
yeah it seems to me like kind of
everybody's gonna get it
yeah at this point in time man yeah be
cool yeah everybody can get it be cool
well the people is like when you get it
they like want to yell at you for being
irresponsible and for killing my grandma
kevin hart's so much smarter than me
because he got it and then out six
months later like hey
i did have it a few months ago and was
like all right not a big deal
yeah you were like while you had it you
announced it the day i got
hey you got cove and i have a friend who
got it and doesn't
joey lit you up well joey was lit and
lightened me up for going and doing that
show in houston joe rogan why you're
going to houston
what the [ __ ] you doing you want to
catch that [ __ ] wanna catch that [ __ ]
give up give it to your [ __ ] friends
joey come on
well he's worried about getting it you
know and he should be with it was his
health and you know his stature he
should be
you know because i have a uh family
friend my mother-in-law's best friends
their son got he's
22 you know out of shape but he passed
away from it
whoa yeah he's 22. 22. so there's like
those outliers
how out of shape is it you know pretty
you know not like obese probably
510 280 290. that's not obese
i mean that's obese but i'm saying he's
not like you know he's not on tlc 600
pound live for nothing
that's so that's morbidly obesity yeah
great that's he's a hundred pounds
overweight yeah he's
he's heavy yeah [ __ ] though that's crazy
22 22. can we do heartbreaking
that's what was that's what's such a
bummer man it's like
we have such a problem with obesity in
this country and poor diet
and that is the number one comorbidity
factor apparently for covet deaths
is being overweight it should be a
wake-up call get in shape
jesus christ it should be but you know
i've had overweight people on the
podcast i'm like you do anything about
it i can't wait for the vaccine
like what about now what about now when
i went to tim dylan's house
to pick him up because he was co-hosting
this thing with me i go to pick him up
because he lives pretty close to me
just come in check out the new pad man
we go into this room and there's workout
equipment he goes
so here's my elliptical that i stare at
every morning there's my treadmill that
i like to take pictures of
like you don't use him he's like nah i
just i don't know man i got him here
though
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience
you